there's a lot of things in this movie
which really crossed the line of
legality actors are definitely a
different breed there are some truly odd
insane and downright dangerous things
this list of performers did to give an
authentic performance
number one things got a little scary on
set Evan Peters prepared so well for his
eerily accurate role as Jeffrey Dahmer
so well in fact that the cast and crew
couldn't distinguish him from his
character most of the time aside from
the extensive research he did on Dahmer
Evan Peters put weights on his arms to
recreate his walking style he wore his
costume shoes jeans and glasses for
months to really get into character all
of this really took a toll on his
emotional well-being doing the role I
wanted to give it a hundred and twenty
percent the whole way through so I
brought in a lot of darkness and
negativity it was just having that end
goal in sight knowing when we were going
to rap and finally be able to breathe
and Let It Go number two we are
definitely not trying to hold our breath
for six minutes Tom Cruise did an
incredibly dangerous underwater stunt
for Mission Impossible Rogue Nation
usually in underwater sequences you'd
hold your breath for 10 to 15 seconds at
a time but Tom Cruise was the first one
to push those limits Tom's very
comfortable underwater he likes to
challenge the crew by staying under
longer than he should even though he
trained with military professionals the
entire cast and crew were pretty
concerned every time he would go
underwater but he ended up filming the
entire underwater sequence swimmingly
with no Cuts number three stepping into
the shoes of Marilyn Monroe is no easy
feat right now we're talking about
Michelle Williams depiction of the
iconic movie star in the film My Week
with Marilyn she had to undergo a
plethora of uncomfortable tasks like
staying in the hair and makeup chair for
hours bleaching her Roots every few days
and ultimately the most insane thing in
our opinion was tying her knees together
with a belt she did that to perfect
Marilyn's signature walk she also found
the role to be incredibly draining and
would wake up in cold sweats and often
cry on her way home from work the other
day someone asked me how I got her
sadness I don't think I ever cried so
much for somebody I didn't know number
four there was a lot of intensity on the
The Amazing Spider-Man 2 set with Andrew
Garfield as Peter Parker and Emma Stone
as Gwen Stacy things got pretty
emotional before shooting the big scene
where Gwen meets her ultimate demise
before shooting it Andrew Garfield
ignored Emma Stone for an entire week
deliberately choosing not to see her the
VFX supervisor Jerome Chen recounts the
Eerie feeling on set that week it was
very quiet the sets were almost always
very quiet Mark likes to work very
focused so it was very quiet a totally
closed set and I just remember Andrew
coming in and just crying uncontrollably
it was hours of that that was grueling
but powerful number five you have to be
more than human to fill the shoes of
Black Adam Dwayne Johnson truly went
above and beyond for his Black Adam
training much further than he's ever
pushed himself throughout his career the
training was so intense it's
questionable whether he can actually
keep putting his body through it if it
ends up becoming a franchise he talked
on Instagram about his insane training
regimen saying he's been conditioning
harder than he ever has in his life
manipulating water sodium cardio but
also having to push and pull real iron
to have dense dry detailed muscle it's a
real science that takes months and
months to dial in with all my strength
and conditioning coach number six let's
talk about Margot Robbie's performance
in I Tonya obviously to be able to play
the infamous figure skater you have to
be extremely comfortable on the ice and
that's exactly what Margot Robbie
intended she did an insane amount of
training for the movie for five straight
months she trained five days a week for
four hours a day she didn't even take
time off for Christmas Eve New Year's
Eve or even the day before her wedding
number seven really though is there
anything Zendaya can't do when shooting
the movie The Greatest showman the
director wanted to use stunt doubles as
little as possible that wish was
definitely granted Zendaya started
learning to Trapeze three months before
shooting started in order to perform the
stunts herself there were a lot of
mishaps and pain in involved when
bringing these scenes to life in one
part we swing away from each other come
together and start spinning there's a
good take of just slapping together and
it's painful number eight it's one thing
to skip breakfast but two days without
eating Daniel Radcliffe really got into
character when filming his movie jungle
about the real life survival of yossi
Ginsburg who had to survive all alone in
the Amazon jungle after an accident to
really feel the same energy of his
character Daniel Radcliffe didn't eat
any food for two days straight I'm not a
method actor at all but I feel like I
would be making my job harder and not
doing Justice to this guy's story if I
was going homie tonight to a steak
dinner and living really comfortably
number nine can you imagine living with
your co-workers for a month when filming
the movie Blue Valentine Michelle
Williams and Ryan Gosling played a
married couple with a daughter the
directors wanted the actors to live
together for at least a month so they
would be more emotionally in tune with
what they were filming they only did it
during the day because Michelle Williams
would go home every night to see her
actual daughter we had to cook and then
clean up and take out the trash you know
build as close to a family as possible
number 10. we're not surprised that
going method as a robber isn't great for
your mental health when filming the
movie Good Time Robert Pattinson really
went full method and tried to emulate
his character's life he lived in a
basement apartment and kept the curtain
Shut for two months he also made jokes
about getting mercury poisoning That's
you and what appears to be a dog cage
yeah why are you in in are things that
Rob I mean are those what number 11 not
the road trip kind the acid kind to
prepare for his role as Charlie
Countryman Shia LaBeouf decided to go
only a little bit method I'm super
nervous right now because this is a wild
experience for me in the film Charlie
trips on acid Shia LaBeouf had never
done it at the time so he decided to not
only did he actually take the trip but
he filmed it and sent it to his co-stars
like Evan Rachel Wood for notes and
feedback number 12. it seems to be a
theme that playing Marilyn Monroe is
extremely difficult Anna De armas really
stepped out of her comfort zone to
depict Marilyn in the fictional biopic
Blonde one thing to armas really
struggled with was her dialect she
worked with a dialect coach for three to
four hours a day and felt extremely
secure on set I put aside what wasn't
helpful for the part and I kept the rest
feeling nervous feeling insecure feeling
like I was not being at times as good as
I wanted to be feeling judged all of
those things I felt myself and they
worked for the role digging into those
emotions also put a strain on her
well-being and she would find herself
crying alone in her apartment just
sitting in a feeling of dread that she
couldn't do anything to help the late
Marilyn number 13. more method acting
techniques for Daniel Radcliffe in the
movie horns he plays a character who is
suspected of committing a brutal crime
against his girlfriend he also has horns
on his head it has all this darkness and
this intensity and this emotional core
but it is also very funny to get into
character Daniel Radcliffe created a
specific playlist and listened to it
non-stop one of his favorites was
Sweating Bullets by Megadeth it's an
insane song and it sounds like a
psychopath talking to himself and that
was very helpful another band he had on
the playlist was a place to bury
strangers it's a hard one to recommend
to people it borders on unlistenable
sometimes it's very representative of
what I felt eggs World sounded like in
his head at the beginning of the movie
before I did the scenes I'd just be
trying to deafen myself with a place to
bury strangers it's insane how much
these actors do to prepare for their
roles living with their co-stars
sleeping in dark basements for two
months and dropping acid just to give
the audience a more authentic experience
that's definitely a lot to commend who's
your favorite actor on this list don't
forget to like And subscribe to the
things